good morning believe nation today's
message is think big over to you Sean
Combs we dream big we dream out at a box
and we dream out of the reality of our
circumstances of a lot of us come from
the inner cities and we want to be
somebody but after you have your dream
and you have your vision you have to
open your eyes and see and deal with
reality of what it's going to take for
you to achieve that dream and now the
real work begins thinking big is
important because it keeps you motivated
when times get tough when you feel like
you don't want to go another day that
bigger picture helps get you out of bed
and get you to work for one more day
thinking big also helps motivate
everybody around you and motivates your
team and motivates your customers and
motivates your suppliers your partner's
media investors because everybody wants
to be a part of something bigger but
thinking big isn't enough you got to
take action on it it's not enough to
think big one day and then the next day
not take action it's not enough to
commit to somebody and then the next day
not follow through it's not enough to
complain about your present
circumstances and then not take action
to try to make them better I'm reminded
of the story of Prince Harvey who was
sent to me by jasons a friend of the
channel and Prince Harvey hazar is a
rapper and you had this big dream of
starting his rap career but his first
computer broke down his second computer
was stolen from him and he had every
reason in the world to say look at my
present circumstances I'm not able to
take action on my big dreams and said
what he did was he went to the New York
Soho apple store every day for four
months and recorded his album off of
their laptops and he released his album
and everybody's talking about it don't
let your present circumstances hold you
back from taking action on your big
dreams
so my question of the day today is about
being resourceful instead of thinking
about your lack of resources I want you
to share a story their own story or one
that you've heard of where an
entrepreneur went above and beyond to
tap into their unlimited resource
fulness like Prince Harvey did to get a
goal accomplished when they didn't have
the resources they need [ __ ] in the
comments below I'm really curious to see
what you have to say thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso